The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last
lecture, we laid out
the foundations of
quantum stat mech.
And to remind you,
in quantum mechanics
we said we could very
formally describe a state
through a vector
in Hilbert space
that has complex components
in terms of some basis
that we haven't specified.
And quantum mechanics
describes, essentially
what happens to one
of these states,
how to interpret it, et cetera.
But this was, in our
language, a pure state.
We were interested in cases
where we have an ensemble
and there are many members
of the ensemble that
correspond to the same
macroscopic state.
And we can distinguish
them macroscopically.
If we think about each
one of those states
being one particular
member, psi alpha,
some vector in this
Hilbert space occurring
with some probability
P alpha, then that's
kind of a more
probabilistic representation
of what's going on here
for the mech state.
And the question was, well,
how do we manipulate things
when we have a collection of
states in this mixed form?
And we saw that in
quantum mechanics,
most of the things
that are observable
are expressed in
terms of matrices.
And one way to convert a
state vector into a matrix
is to conjugate it and construct
the matrix whose elements are
obtained-- a particular rho
vector by taking element
and complex conjugate
elements of the vector.
And if we were to then sum over
all members of this ensemble,
this would give us an object
that we call the density
matrix, rho.
And the property of
this density matrix
was that if I had some
observable for a pure state
I would be able to
calculate an expectation
value for this observable
by sandwiching it
between the state in the way
that quantum mechanic has
taught us.
In our mech state, we would
get an ensemble average
of this quantity by
multiplying this density matrix
with the matrix that represents
the operator whose average we
are trying to calculate,
and then taking
the trace of the product
of these two matrices.
Now, the next statement
was that in the same way
that the micro-state classically
changes as a function of time,
the vector that we have
in quantum mechanics
is also changing as
a function of time.
And so at a different
instant of time,
our state vectors have changed.
And in principle, our
density has changed.
And that would imply a change
potentially in the average
that we have over here.
We said, OK, let's look
at this time dependence.
And we know that these psis
obey Schrodinger equation.
I h bar d psi by dt is h psi.
So we did the same
operation, I h bar d
by dt of this density matrix.
And we found that
essentially, what we
would get on the other
side is the commutator
of the density
matrix and the matrix
corresponding to
the Hamiltonian,
which was reminiscent of
the Liouville statement
that we had classically.
Classically, we had
that d rho by dt
was the Poisson bracket of a
rho with H versus this quantum
formulation.
Now, in both cases
we are looking
for some kind of a density
that represents an equilibrium
ensemble.
And presumably,
the characteristic
of the equilibrium ensemble
is that various measurements
that you make at one time and
another time are the same.
And hence, we want
this rho equilibrium
to be something that does not
change as a function of time,
which means that if we put it in
either one of these equations,
the right-hand side for
d rho by dt should be 0.
And clearly, a
simple way to do that
is to make rho equilibrium
be a function of H.
In the classical context, H
was a function in phase space.
Rho equilibrium was,
therefore, made a function
of various points in
phase space implicitly
through its dependence on
H. In the current case,
H is a matrix in Hilbert space.
A function of a matrix
is another function,
and that's how we
construct rho equilibrium.
And that function will
also commute with H
because clearly H with H is 0.
Any function of H
with H will be 0.
So the prescription that
we have in order now
to construct the quantum
statistical mechanics
is to follow what we had done
already for the classical case.
And classically
following this equation,
we made postulates
relating rho--
what its functional
dependence was
on H. We can now do the same
thing in the quantum context.
So let's do that
following the procedure
that we followed for
the classical case.
So classically, we
said, well, let's look
at an ensemble that
was micro-canonical.
So in the
micro-canonical ensemble,
we specified what the
energy of the system was,
but we didn't allow either
work to be performed
on it mechanically or chemically
so that the number of elements
was fixed.
The coordinates, such as
volume, length of the system,
et cetera, were fixed.
And in this ensemble,
classically the statement
was that rho indexed by
E is a function of H.
And clearly, what we
want is to only allow
H's that correspond
to the right energy.
So I will use a kind
of shorthand notation
as kind of a delta H E.
Although, when we were doing
it last time around, we allowed
this function to allow a
range of possible E-values.
I can do the same thing, it's
just that writing that out
is slightly less convenient.
So let's stick with
the convenient form.
Essentially, it says
within some range delta A
allow the Hamiltonians.
Allow states, micro-states,
whose Hamiltonian
would give the right energy
that is comparable to the energy
that we have said exists
for the macro-state.
Now clearly also,
this definition
tells me that the trace
of rho has to be 1.
Or classically, the integral
of rho E over the entire phase
space has to be 1.
So there is a
normalization condition.
And this normalization condition
gave us the quantity omega
of E, the number of
states of energy E,
out of which we then
constructed the entropy
and we were running
away calculating
various thermodynamic
quantities.
So now let's see how we evaluate
this in the quantum case.
We will use the same
expression, but now me
realize that rho is a matrix.
So I have to evaluate, maybe
elements of that matrix
to clarify what this matrix
looks like in some basis.
What's the most
convenient basis?
Since rho is expressed
as a function of H,
the most convenient basis
is the energy basis,
which is the basis that
diagonalizes your Hamiltonian
matrix.
Basically, there's some
vectors in this Hilbert space
such that the
action of H on this
will give us some
energy that I will
call epsilon n, some eigenvalue.
An n.
So that's the definition
of the energy basis.
Again, as all basis, we can
make these basis vectors
n to be unit length and
orthogonal to each other.
There is an orthonormal basis.
If I evaluate rho E in
this basis, what do I find?
I find that n rho m.
Well, 1 over omega E
is just the constant.
It comes out front.
And the meaning of this delta
function becomes obvious.
It is 1 or 0.
It is 1 if, let's say, Em
equals to the right energy.
Em is the right energy
for the ensemble E.
And of course, there
is a delta function.
So there is also
an m equals to n.
And it is 0, clearly, for states
that have the wrong energy.
But there is an
additional thing here
that I will explain shortly
for m not equal to n.
So let's parse
the two statements
that I have made over here.
The first one, it
says that if I know
the energy of my
macro-state, I clearly
have to find wave
functions to construct
possible states of
what is in the box that
have the right energy.
States that don't have the
right energy are not admitted.
States that are
the right energy,
I have nothing against
each one of them.
So I give them all
the same probability.
So this is our whole
assumption of equal equilibrium
a priori probabilities.
But now I have a quantum system
and I'm looking at the matrix.
And this matrix potentially
has off-diagonal elements.
You see, if I am looking
at m equals to n,
it means that I am looking
at the diagonal elements
of the matrix.
What this says is that if the
energies are degenerate-- let's
say I have 100 states, all of
them have the right energy,
but they are orthonormal.
These 100 states, when I
look at the density matrix
in the corresponding basis,
the off-diagonal elements
would be 0.
So this is the "or."
So even if this
condition is satisfied,
even if Em equals to
E, but I am looking
at off-diagonal elements,
I have to put 0.
And this is sometimes called
the assumption of random phases.
Before telling you
why that's called
an assumption of random
phases, let's also
characterize what
this omega of E is.
Because trace of rho has
to be 1, clearly omega of E
is the trace of this
delta h E. Essentially
as I scan all of my
possible energy levels
in this energy
basis, I will get 1
for those that have the
right energy and 0 otherwise.
So basically, this is simply
number of states of energy E,
potentially with minus
plus some delta E
if I want to include that.
Now, what these assumptions
mean are kind of like this.
So I have my box
and I have been told
that I have energy E. What's
a potential wave function
that I can have in this box?
What's the psi given that I
know what the energy E is?
Well, any superposition
of these omega E states
that have the right
energy will work fine.
So I have a sum
over, let's say, mu
that belongs to the
state such that H-- such
that this energy En
is equal to the energy
that I have specified.
And there are omega
sub E such states.
I have to find some kind of
an amplitude for these states,
and then the
corresponding state mu.
I guess I should
write here E mu.
Now, the first
statement over here
is that as far as
I'm concerned, I
can put all of these a
mu's in whatever proportion
that I want.
Any linear combination
will work out fine.
Because ultimately, psi
has to be normalized.
Presumably, the
typical magnitude a m
squared, if I average over
all members of the ensemble,
should be 1 over omega.
So this is a superposition.
Typically, all of
them would contribute.
But since we are thinking
about quantum mechanics,
these amplitudes can,
in fact, be complex.
And this statement
of random phases
is more or less
equivalent to saying
that the phases of
the different elements
would be typically
uncorrelated when you average
over all possible
members of this ensemble.
Just to emphasize this
a little bit more,
let's think about the
very simplest case
that we can have for
thinking about probability.
And you would think
of, say, a coin that
can have two possibilities,
head or tail.
So classically, you
would say, head or tail,
not knowing anything
else, are equally likely.
The quantum analog of
that is a quantum bit.
And the qubit can have,
let's say, up or down states.
It's a Hilbert space that
is composed of two elements.
So the corresponding matrix that
I would have would be a 2 by 2.
And according to the
construction that I have,
it will be something like this.
What are the possible wave
functions for this system?
I can have any
linear combination
of, say, up and down,
with any amplitude here.
And so essentially, the
amplitudes, presumably,
are quantities that I will
call alpha up and alpha down.
That, on average, alpha squared
up or down would be 1/2.
That's what would appear here.
The elements that
appear here according
to the construction
that I have up there,
I have to really
take this element,
average it against the complex
conjugate of that element.
So what will appear here
would be something like e
to the i phi of up minus phi
of down, where, let's say,
I put here phi of up.
And what I'm saying
is that there
are a huge number
of possibilities.
Whereas, the classical coin has
really two possibilities, head
or tail, the quantum
analog of this
is a huge set of possibilities.
These phis can be
anything, 0 to 2 pi.
Independent of each
other, the amplitudes
can be anything as long as
the eventual normalization
is satisfied.
And as you sort of sum
over all possibilities,
you would get something
like this also.
Now, the more convenient
ensemble for calculating things
is the canonical one, where
rather than specifying
what the energy
of the system is,
I tell you what
the temperature is.
I still don't allow
work to take place,
so these other
elements we kept fixed.
And our classical
description for rho sub T
was e to the minus
beta H divided
by some partition function,
where beta was 1 over kT,
of course.
So again, in the energy
basis, this would be diagonal.
And the diagonal elements would
be e to the minus beta epsilon
n.
I could calculate the
normalization Z, which
would be trace of e
to the minus beta H.
This trace is calculated
most easily the basis
in which H is diagonal.
And then I just pick out all
of the diagonal elements, sum
over n e to the
minus beta epsilon.
Now if you recall, we already
did something like this
without justification
where we said
that the states of a harmonic
oscillator, we postulated
to be quantized h
bar omega n plus 1/2.
And then we calculated
the partition function
by summing over all states.
You can see that
this would provide
the justification for that.
Now, various things that we have
in classical formulations also
work, such that
classically if we had Z,
we could take the
log of Z. We could
take a derivative of log
Z with respect to beta.
It would bring
down a factor of H.
And then we show that this
was equal to the average
of the energy.
It was the average of
Hamiltonian, which we then
would identify with the
thermodynamic energy.
It is easy to show that if you
take the same set of operations
over here, what you would
get is trace of H rho, which
is the definition of the
average that you find.
Now, let's do one example
in the canonical ensemble,
which is particle in box.
Basically, this is the kind of
thing that we did all the time.
We assume that there is
some box of volume v.
And for the time being, I
just put one particle in it.
Assume that there
is no potential.
So the Hamiltonian
for this one particle
is just its kinetic
energy p1 squared over 2m,
maybe plus some kind
of a box potential.
Now, if I want to think about
this quantum mechanically,
I have to think about
some kind of a basis
and calculating things
in some kind of basis.
So for the time
being, let's imagine
that I do things in
coordinate basis.
So I want to have
where the particle is.
And let's call
the coordinates x.
Let's say, a vector x that
has x, y, and z-components.
Then, in the
coordinate basis, p is
h bar over i, the
gradient vector.
So this becomes minus h bar
squared Laplacian over 2m.
And if I want to
look at what are
the eigenstates of his
Hamiltonian represented
in coordinates basis,
as usual I want
to have something like H1 acting
on some function of position
giving me the energy.
And so I will indicate that
function of position as x k.
And I want to know
what that energy is.
And the reason I do
that is because you all
know that the correct form
of these eigenfunctions
are things like e
to the i k dot x.
And since I want these to be
normalized when I integrate
over all coordinates, I have
to divide by square root of V.
So that's all nice and fine.
What I want to do is to
calculate the density matrix
in this coordinate basis.
So I pick some
point x prime rho x.
And it's again, a one particle.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was thinking
the box to be infinite
or-- I mean, how to treat a
boundary because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So I wasn't
careful about that.
The allowed values of k
that I have to pick here
will reflect the
boundary conditions.
And indeed, I will be able
to use these kinds of things.
Let's say, by using
periodic boundary condition.
And if I choose periodic
boundary conditions,
the allowed values of
k will be quantized.
So that, say, kx
would be multiples
of 2 pi over Lx
times some integer.
If I use really box boundary
conditions such as the wave
function having to
vanish at the two ends,
in reality I should use
the sine and cosine type
of boundary wave functions,
which are superpositions
of these e to the i kx
and e to the minus i kx.
And they slightly change
the normalization--
the discretization.
But up to, again, these kinds
of superpositions and things
like that, this is a
good enough statement.
If you are really doing
quantum mechanics,
you have to clearly
be more careful.
Just make sure that I'm
sufficiently careful, but not
overly careful in
what I'm doing next.
So what do I need to do?
Well, rho 1 is
nicely diagonalized
in the basis of
these plane waves.
In these eigenstates
of the Hamiltonian.
So it makes sense for me to
switch from this representation
that is characterized
by x and x prime
to a representation
where I have k.
And so I can do that by
inserting a sum over k here.
And then I have rho 1.
Rho 1 is simply e
to the minus beta.
It is diagonal in
this basis of k's.
There is a normalization that
we call Z1, partition function.
And because it is
diagonal, in fact
I will use the same k
on both sides of this.
So the density matrix is, in
fact, diagonal in momentum.
This is none other than
momentum, of course.
But I don't want to calculate
the density matrix in momentum
where it is diagonal because
that's the energy basis we
already saw, but in
coordinate basis.
So now let's write
all of these things.
First of all, the sum over
k when l becomes large,
I'm going to replace
with an integral over k.
And then I have to
worry about the spacing
that I have between k-values.
So that will multiply with
a density of states, which
is 2 pi cubed product
of lx, ly, lz,
which will give me
the volume of the box.
And then I have these factors
of-- how did I define it?
kx is e to the i k dot x.
And this thing where k and
x prime are interchanged
is its complex conjugate.
So it becomes x minus x prime.
I have two factors of 1
over square root of V,
so that will give me
a factor of 1 over V
from the product
of these things.
And then I still
have minus beta h bar
squared k squared over 2m.
And then I have the Z1.
Before proceeding, maybe
it's worthwhile for me
to calculate the
Z1 in this case.
So Z1 is the trace of rho 1.
It's essentially the same thing.
It's a sum over k e
to the minus beta h
bar squared k squared over 2m.
I do the same thing
that I did over there,
replace this with V integral
over k divided by 2 pi cubed
e to the minus beta h bar
squared k squared over 2m.
I certainly recognize h bar k
as the same thing as momentum.
This is really p squared.
So just let me write
this after rescaling
all of the k's by h bar.
So then what I would have is
an integral over momentum.
And then for each
k, I essentially
bring down a factor of h bar.
What is 2 pi h bar?
2 pi h bar is h.
So I would have a
factor of h cubed.
I have an integration over
space that gave me volume.
e to the minus beta h
bar-- p squared over 2m.
Why did I write it this way?
Because it should remind
you of how we made
dimensionless the
integrations that we
had to do for
classical calculations.
Classical partition
function, if I
wanted to calculate
within a single particle,
for a single
particle Hamiltonian,
I would have this
Boltzmann weight.
I have to integrate over all
coordinates, over all momenta.
And then we divided by h
to make it dimensionless.
So you can see that that
naturally appears here.
And so the answer to
this is V over lambda
cubed with the lambda
that we had defined
before as h over root 2 pi m kT.
So you can see that this
traces that we write down
in this quantum
formulations are clearly
dimensionless quantities.
And they go over to
the classical limit
where we integrate over
phase space appropriately
dimensional-- made
dimensionless by dividing
by h per combination of p and q.
So this V1 we already
know is V-- Z1
we already know is
V over lambda cubed.
The reason I got a
little bit confused
was because I saw that
the V's were disappearing.
And then I remembered,
oh, Z1 is actually
proportional to mu
over lambda cubed.
So that's good.
So what we have here from
the inverse of Z1 is a 1
over V lambda cubed here.
Now, then I have to complete
this kind of integration,
which are Gaussian integrations.
If x was equal to
x prime, this would
be precisely the integration
that I'm doing over here.
So if x was equal to x
prime, that integration,
the Gaussian integration,
would have given me
this 1 over lambda cubed.
But because I have this
shift-- in some sense
I have to shift k to remove
that shift in x minus x prime.
And when I square
it, I will get here
a factor, which is exponential,
of minus x minus x prime
squared-- the Square
of that factor-- times
the variance of k, which
is m kT over h bar squared.
So what do I get here?
I will get 2.
And then I would get
essentially m kT.
And then, h bar squared here.
Now, this combination m kT
divided by h, same thing
as here, m kT and h.
Clearly, what that is, is
giving me some kind of a lambda.
So let me write the answer.
Eventually, what I
find is that evaluating
the one-particle density
matrix between two points, x
and x prime, will
give me 1 over V.
And then this
exponential factor,
which is x minus
x prime squared.
The coefficient here has to be
proportional to lambda squared.
And if you do the
algebra right, you
will find that the
coefficient is pi over 2.
Or is it pi?
Let me double check.
It's a numerical factor
that is not that important.
It is pi, pi over
lambda squared.
OK, so what does this mean?
So I have a particle in the box.
It's a quantum mechanical
particle at some temperature T.
And I'm trying to
ask, where is it?
So if I want to ask
where is it, what's
the probability it
is at some point x?
I refer to this
density matrix that I
have calculated in
coordinate space.
Put x prime and
x to be the same.
If x prime and x are the
same, I get 1 over V.
Essentially, it says
that the probability
that I find a particle is
the same anywhere in the box.
So that makes sense.
It is the analog of
throwing the coin.
We don't know where
the particle is.
It's equally likely
to be anywhere.
Actually, remember that I used
periodic boundary conditions.
If I had used sine
and cosines, there
would have been some dependence
on approaching the boundaries.
But the matrix tells
me more than that.
Basically, the matrix
says it is true
that the diagonal
elements are 1 over V.
But if I go off-diagonal,
there is this [INAUDIBLE] scale
lambda that is
telling me something.
What is it telling you?
Essentially, it is telling you
that through the procedures
that we have outlined here, if
you are at the temperature T,
then this factor tells you
about the classical probability
of finding a momentum p.
There is a range of momenta
because p squared over 2m,
the excitation is
controlled by kT.
There is a range of
momenta that is possible.
And through a
procedure such as this,
you are making a
superposition of plane waves
that have this
range of momentum.
The superposition of plane
waves, what does it give you?
It essentially gives
you a Guassian blob,
which we can position
anywhere in the space.
But the width of
that Gaussian blob
is given by this
factor of lambda,
which is related to
the uncertainty that
is now quantum in character.
That is, quantum mechanically
if you know the momentum,
then you don't
know the position.
There is the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle.
Now we have a
classical uncertainty
about the momentum because
of these Boltzmann weights.
That classical uncertainty
that we have about the momentum
translates to some kind of a
wave packet size for these--
to how much you can
localize a particle.
So really, this
particle you should
think of quantum mechanically
as being some kind of a wave
packet that has some
characteristic size lambda.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So could you
interpret the difference
between x and x prime
appearing in the [INAUDIBLE]
as sort of being the probability
of finding a particle at x
having turned to x
prime within the box?
PROFESSOR: At this
stage, you are
sort of introducing
something that is not there.
But if I had two
particles-- so very soon we
are going to do
multiple particles--
and this kind of structure
will be maintained
if I have multiple particles,
then your statement is correct.
That this factor will
tell me something
about the probability of
these things being exchanged,
one tunneling to the other
place and one tunneling back.
And indeed, if you went to
the colloquium yesterday,
Professor [? Block ?]
showed pictures
of these kinds of
exchanges taking place.
OK?
But essentially,
really at this stage
for the single particle
with no potential,
the statement is that the
particle is, in reality,
some kind of a wave packet.
OK?
Fine.
So any other questions?
The next thing is, of
course, what I said.
Let's put two particles
in the potential.
So let's go to two particles.
Actually, not necessarily
even in the box.
But let's say what
kind of a Hamiltonian
would I write for two particles?
I would write something
that has a kinetic energy
for the first particle, kinetic
energy for the second particle,
and then some kind of a
potential of interaction.
Let's say, as a
function of x1 minus x2.
Now, I could have done many
things for two particles.
I could, for example,
have had particles
that are different
masses, but I clearly
wanted to write things
that were similar.
So this is Hamiltonian
that describes
particles labeled by 1 and 2.
And if they have the same
mass and the potential
is a function of
separation, it's
certainly h that is
for 2 and 1 exchange.
So this Hamiltonian
has a certain symmetry
under the exchange
of the labels.
Now typically, what
you should remember
is that any type of symmetry
that your Hamiltonian has
or any matrix has will
be reflected ultimately
in the form of the
eigenvectors that you
would construct for that.
So indeed, I already
know that for this, I
should be able to construct
wave functions that
are either symmetrical or
anti-symmetric under exchange.
But that statement
aside, let's think
about the meaning
of the wave function
that we have for
the two particles.
So presumably, there is a psi
as a function of x1 and x2
in the coordinate space.
And for a particular
quantum state,
you would say that the
square of this quantity
is related to quantum
probabilities of finding
particles at x1 and x2.
So this could, for example,
be the case of two particles.
Let's say oxygen and nitrogen.
They have almost the same mass.
This statement would be true.
But the statement
becomes more interesting
if we say that the
particles are identical.
So for identical
particles, the statement
of identity in quantum mechanics
is damped at this stage.
You would say that I can't
tell apart the probability
that one particle,
number 1, is at x1,
particle 2 is at
x2 or vice versa.
The labels 1 and
2 are just thinks
that I assign for
convenience, but they really
don't have any meaning.
There are two particles.
To all intents and purposes,
they are identical.
And there is some probability
for seeing the events
where one particle--
I don't know
what its label is--
at this location.
The other particle-- I don't
know what its label is--
is at that location.
Labels don't have any meaning.
So this is different.
This does not have
a classic analog.
Classically, if I put
something on the computer,
I would say that
particle 1 is here at x1,
particle 2 is here at x2.
I have to write some
index on the computer.
But if I want to
construct a wave function,
I wouldn't know what to do.
I would just essentially
have a function of x1 and x2
that is peaked here and there.
And we also know that somehow
quantum mechanics tells us
that there is
actually a stronger
version of this statement,
which is that psi of x1, x2 x1
is either plus psi of
x1, x2 or minus psi
of x1, x2 for
identical particles
depending on whether they
are boson or fermions.
So let's kind of build
upon that a little bit more
and go to many particles.
So forth N particles
that are identical,
I would have some
kind of a state psi
that depends on the coordinates.
For example, in the
coordinate representation,
but I could choose any
other representation.
Coordinate kind of
makes more sense.
We can visualize it.
And if I can't tell
them apart, previously I
was just exchanging
two of the labels
but now I can permute
them in any possible way.
So I can add the permutation
P. And of course, there
are N factorial in number.
And the generalization of the
statement that I had before
was that for the
case of bosons, I
will always get the
same thing back.
And for the case of fermions,
I will get a number back
that is either minus
or plus depending
on the type of permutation that
I apply of what I started with.
So I have introduced here
something that I call minus 1
to the power of
P, which is called
a parity of the permutation.
A permutation is either even--
in which case, this minus 1
to the power of P is plus--
or is odd-- in which case,
this minus 1 to P is minus 1.
How do I determine the
parity of permutation?
Parity of the
permutation is the number
of exchanges that lead
to this permutation.
Basically, take any permutation.
Let's say we stick
with four particles.
And I go from 1, 2, 3,
4, which was, let's say,
some regular ordering,
to some other ordering.
Let's say 4, 2, 1, 2.
And my claim is that I can
achieve this transformation
through a series of exchanges.
So I can get here as follows.
I want 4 to come all
the way back to here,
so I do an exchange of 1 and 4.
I call the exchange
in this fashion.
I do exchange of 1 and 4.
The exchange of 1 and 4
will make for me 4, 2, 3, 1.
OK.
I compare this with this.
I see that all I need to
do is to switch 3 and 1.
So I do an exchange of 1 and 3.
And what I will get
here is 4, 2, 1, 3.
So I could get to
that permutation
through two exchanges.
Therefore, this is even.
Now, this is not
the only way that I
can get from one to the other.
I can, for example, sit and do
multiple exchanges of this 4,
2 a hundred times, but
not ninety nine times.
As long as I do
an even number, I
will get back to the same thing.
The parity will be conserved.
And there's another way
of calculating parity.
You just start with this
original configuration
and you want to get to
that final configuration.
You just draw lines.
So 1 goes to 1, 2 goes to
2, 3 goes to 3, 4 goes to 4.
And you count how many
crossings you have,
and the parity of
those crossings
will give you the parity
of the permutation.
So somehow within
quantum mechanics,
the idea of what is
identical particle is stamped
into the nature of
the wave vectors,
in the structure of the Hilbert
space that you can construct.
So let's see how that leads to
this simple example of particle
in the box, if we continue to
add particles into the box.
So we want to now put
N particles in box.
Otherwise, no interaction
completely free.
So the N particle Hamiltonian is
some alpha running from 1 to N
p alpha squared over
2m kinetic energies
of all of these things.
fine.
Now, note that this Hamiltonian,
since it is in some sense
built up of lots of
non-interacting pieces.
And we saw already classically,
that things are not
interacting-- calculating
probabilities,
partition functions, et
cetera, is very easy.
This has that same structure.
It's the ideal gas.
Now, quantum mechanically.
So it should be
sufficiently easy.
And indeed, we can immediately
construct the eigenstates
for this.
So we can construct
the basis, and then
do the calculations
in that basis.
So let's look at something
that I will call product state.
And let's say that
I had this structure
that I described on the board
above where I have a plane
wave that is characterized
by some wave number
k for one particle.
For N particles, I pick
the first one to be k1,
the second one to be k2,
the last one to be kN.
And I will call this a
product state in the sense
that if I look at the positional
representation of this product
state, it is simply the
product of one-particle states.
So this is a product
over alpha of x alpha
k alpha, which is
this e to the i kx
k dot x over square root of it.
So this is perfectly
well normalized
if I were to integrate
over x1, x2, x3.
Each one of the integrals
is individually normalized.
The overall thing is normalized.
It's an eigenstate because
if I act Hn on this product
state, what I will get is a
sum over alpha h bar squared
k alpha squared over 2m, and
then the product state back.
So it's an eigenstate.
And in fact, it's a
perfectly good eigenstate
as long as I want to
describe a set of particles
that are not identical.
I can't use this state
to describe particles
that are identical
because it does not
satisfy the symmetries that
I set quantum mechanics
stamps into identical particles.
And it's clearly the case that,
for example-- so this is not
symmetrized since clearly,
if I look at k1, k2,
k1 goes with x1,
k2 goes with x2.
And it is not the
same thing as k2, k1,
where k2 goes with x1
and k1 goes with x2.
Essentially, the two particles
can be distinguished.
One of them has
momentum h bar k1.
The other has
momentum h bar k 2.
I can tell them apart because
of this unsymmetrized nature
of this wave function.
But you know how to make
things that are symmetric.
You basically add k1 k2 plus
k2 k1 or k1 k2 minus k2 k1
to make it anti-symmetrized.
Divide by square root
of 2 and you are done.
So now, let's generalize
that to the case
of the N-particle system.
So I will call a-- let's
start with the case
of the fermionic state.
In fermionic state,
I will indicate
by k1, k2, kN with a
minus index because
of the asymmetry
or the minus signs
that we have for fermions.
The way I do that is I
sum over all N factorial
permutations that I have.
I let p act on
the product state.
And again, for two particles,
you have the k1 k2,
then you do minus k2 k1.
For general particles, I do
this minus 1 to the power of p.
So all the even permutations
are added with plus.
All the odd permutations
are added with minus.
Except that this is a whole
bunch of different terms
that are being added.
Again, for two
particles, you know
that you have to divide
by a square root of 2
because you add 2 vectors.
And the length of
the overall vector
is increased by a
square root of 2.
Here, you have to divide in
general by the number of terms
that you have, square
root of N factorial.
The only thing that you have
to be careful with is that you
cannot have any two of
these k's to be the same.
Because let's say these two are
the same, then along the list
here I have the
exchange of these two.
And when I exchange them,
I go from even to odd.
I put a minus sign and
I have a subtraction.
So here, I have to
make sure that all k
alpha must be distinct.
Now, say the bosonic
one is simpler.
I basically construct it,
k1, k2, kN with a plus.
By simply adding
things together,
so I will have a sum over p.
No sign here.
Permutation k1 through kN.
And then I have to divide
by some normalization.
Now, the only tricky
thing about this
is that the normalization
is not N factorial.
So to give you an
example, let's imagine
that I choose to start
with a product state
where two of the k's are
alpha and one of them is beta.
So let's sort of put here 1,
1, 1, 2, 3 for my k1, k2, k3.
I have chosen that k1
and k2 are the same.
And what I have to do is to sum
over all possible permutations.
So there is a permutation
here that is 1, 3, 2.
So I get here
alpha, beta, alpha.
Then I will have 2, 1, 3,
2, 3, 1, 3, 1, 2, 3, 2, 1,
which basically would be alpha,
alpha, beta, alpha, beta,
alpha, beta, alpha,
alpha, beta, alpha, alpha.
So there are for three things,
3 factorial or 6 permutations.
But this entity is
clearly twice alpha,
alpha, beta, plus alpha, beta,
alpha, plus beta, alpha, alpha.
And the norm of this is going
to be 4 times 1 plus 1 plus 1.
4 times 3, which is 12.
So in order to
normalize this, I have
to divide not by 1/6, but 1/12.
So the appropriate
normalization here
then becomes 1 over root 3.
Now, in general what
would be this N plus?
To calculate N plus,
I have to make sure
that the norm of
this entity is 1.
Or, N plus is the
square of this quantity.
And if I were to
square this quantity,
I will get two sets
of permutations.
I will call them p and p prime.
And on one side, I would
have the permutation p of k1
through kN.
On the other side, I would have
a permutation k prime of k1
through kN.
Now, this is clearly N
factorial square terms.
But this is not N factorial
squared distinct terms.
Because essentially,
over here I could
get 1 of N factorial
possibilities.
And then here, I would
permute over all the other N
factorial possibilities.
Then I would try the next
one and the next one.
And essentially,
each one of those
would give me the same one.
So that is, once I have
fixed what this one is,
permuting over them will
give me one member of N
factorial identical terms.
So I can write this as N
factorial sum over Q. Let's say
I start with the
original k1 through kN,
and then I go and do a
permutation of k1 through kN.
And the question
is, how many times
do I get something
that is non-zero?
If these two lists are
completely distinct,
except for the identity
any transformation
that I will make
here will make me
a vector that is orthogonal
to this and I will get 0.
But if I have two of
them that are identical,
then I do a
permutation like this
and I'll get the
same thing back.
And then I have two things that
are giving the same result.
And in general, this
answer is a product
over all multiple
occurrences factorial.
So let's say here
there was something
that was repeated twice.
If it had been
repeated three times,
then all six possibilities
would've been the same.
So I would have had 3 factorial.
So if I had 3 and then 2
other ones that were the same,
then the answer would
have been multiplied
by 3 factorial 2 factorial.
So the statement here
is that this N plus
that I have to put here is N
factorial product over k nk
factorial, which is essentially
the multiplicity that
is associated with repeats.
Oh
So we've figured out what
the appropriate bosonic
and fermionic eigenstates are
for this situation of particles
in the box where I put
multiple particles.
So now I have N
particles in the box.
I know what the appropriate
basis functions are.
And what I can now try
to do is to, for example,
calculate the analog of
the partition function,
the analog of what I did
here for N particles,
or the analog of
the density matrix.
So let's calculate the
analog of the density matrix
and see what happens.
So I want to calculate
an N particle density
matrix, completely
free particles
in a box, no interactions.
For one particle, I
went from x to x prime.
So here, I go from x1, x2, xN.
To here, x1 prime,
x2 prime, xN prime.
Our answer ultimately
will depend on
whether I am dealing
with fermions or bosons.
So I introduce an
index here eta.
Let me put it here, eta is
plus 1 for bosons and minus 1
for fermions.
So kind of goes with
this thing over here
whether or not I'm using bosonic
or fermionic symmetrization
in constructing the
wave functions here.
You say, well, what is rho?
Rho is e to the minus this beta
hn divided by some partition
function ZN that I don't know.
But what I certainly know about
it is because I constructed,
in fact, this basis so that I
have the right energy, which
is sum over alpha
h bar squared alpha
squared k alpha squared over 2m.
That is, this rho is diagonal
in the basis of the k's.
So maybe what I should do
is I should switch from this
representation to the
representation of k's.
So the same way that
for one particle
I sandwiched this
factor of k, I am
going to do the same
thing over here.
Except that I will have
a whole bunch of k's.
Because I'm doing
a multiple system.
What do I have?
I have x1 prime to xN
prime k1 through kN,
with whatever appropriate
symmetry it is.
I have e to the minus
sum over alpha beta h
bar squared k alpha
squared over 2m.
Essentially, generalizing
this factor that I have here,
except that I have to
normalize it with some ZN
that I have yet to calculate.
And then I go back
from k1, kN to x1, xN.
Again, respecting
whatever symmetry I
want to have at
the end of the day.
Now, let's think a little
bit about this summation
that I have to do over here.
And I'll put a prime
up there to indicate
that it is a restricted sum.
I didn't have any
restriction here.
I said I integrate over--
or sum over all possible k's
that were consistent with
the choice of 2 pi over l,
or whatever.
Now, here I have to make sure
that I don't do over-counting.
What do I mean?
I mean that once I do
this symmetrization,
let's say I start with two
particles and I have k1, k2.
Then, I do the symmetrization.
I get something that is a
symmetric version of k1, k2.
I would have gotten
exactly the same thing
if I started with k2, k1.
That is, a particular
one of these states
corresponds to one
list that I have here.
And so over here, I should
not sum over k1, k2, k3, et
cetera, independently.
Because then I will be
over-counting by N factorial.
So I say, OK, let me sum
over things independently
and then divide by
the over-counting.
Because presumably,
these will give me
N factorial similar states.
So let's just sum over all
of them, forget about this.
You say, well, almost.
Not quite because you have
to worry about these factors.
Because now when you
did the N factorial,
you sort of did not
take into account
the kinds of exchanges that I
mentioned that you should not
include because essentially if
you have k1, k1, and then k3,
then you don't have 6
different permutations.
You only have 3
So actually, the correction
that I have to make
is to multiply here
by this quantity.
So now that sum be the
restriction has gone into this.
And this ensures that as I sum
over all k's independently,
the over-counting of
states that I have made
is taken into account by
the appropriate factor.
Now, this is actually
very nice because when
I look at these states, I have
the normalization factors.
The normalizations depend
on the list of k's that I
have over here.
So the normalization of these
objects will give me a 1
over N factorial product
over k nk factorial.
And these nk
factorials will cancel.
Now you say, hang on.
Going too fast.
This eta says you can do this
both for fermions and bosons.
But this calculation
that you did over here
applies only for
the case of bosons.
You say, never mind because for
fermions, the allowed values
of nk are either 0 or 1.
I cannot put two of them.
So these nk factorials are
either-- again, 1 or 1.
So even for fermions,
this will work out fine.
There will be appropriate
cancellation of wave functions
that should not
be included when I
do the summation
over permutations
with the corresponding
factors of plus and minus.
So again, the minus signs--
everything will work.
And this kind of
ugly factor will
disappear at the end of the day.
OK?
Fine.
Now, each one of these is
a sum over permutations.
Actually, before
I write those, let
me just write the factor of e to
the minus sum over alpha beta h
bar squared k alpha
squared over 2m.
And then I have ZN.
I don't know what ZN is yet.
Each one of these states
is a sum over permutations.
I have taken care of the
overall normalization.
I have to do the sum
over the permutations.
And let's say I'm
looking at this one.
Essentially, I have to sandwich
that with some combination
of x's.
What do I get?
I will get a factor
of eta to the p.
So actually, maybe
I should have really
within the following
statement at some point.
So we introduced these
different states.
I can combine them together
and write k1, k2, kN
with a symmetry that
is representative
of bosons or fermions.
And that's where I introduced a
factor of plus or minus, which
is obtained by summing
over all permutations.
This factor eta, which is plus
or minus, raised to the p.
So for bosons, I would be
adding everything in phase.
For fermions, I would
have minus 1 to the p.
I have the permutation
of the set of indices k1
through kN in the product state.
Whoops.
This should be product.
This should be a product state.
And then I have to divide
by square root of N
factorial product
over k nk factorial.
And clearly, and we will see a
useful way of looking at this.
I can also look at the set of
states that are occupied among
the original list of k's.
Some k's do not
occur in this list.
Some k's occurs once.
Some k's occur more than once.
And that's how I
construct these factors.
And then the condition that
I have is that, of course,
sum over k nK should
be the total number
N. That nk is 0
or 1 for fermions.
That nk is any value up to
that constraint for bosons.
Now, I take these functions and
I substitute it here and here.
What do I get?
I get the product state.
So I have eta to the p.
The product state is
e to the i sum over,
let's say, beta k of
p beta x beta prime.
And then from the next one, I
will get e to the minus i sum
over-- again, some other beta.
Or the same beta,
it doesn't matter.
p prime beta x beta.
I think I included everything.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Question.
Why do you only have one
term of beta to the p?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So here I have a list.
It could be k1, k2, k2--
well, let's say k3, k4.
Let's say I have four things.
And the product
means I essentially
have a product of these things.
When I multiply them
with wave functions,
I will have e to the
i, k1, x1 et cetera.
Now, I do some permutation.
Let's say I go from
1, 2, 3 to 3, 2, 1.
So there is a permutation
that I do like that.
I leave the 4 to be the same.
This permutation
has some parity.
So I have to put a plus or minus
that depends on the parity.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But my question is why in
that equation over there--
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: --we have a
term A to the p for the k.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: k factor
and not for the bra.
PROFESSOR: Good.
You are telling me that I forgot
to put p prime and eta of p
prime.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I wasn't sure if
there was a reason.
PROFESSOR: No.
I was going step by step.
I had written the bra part and I
was about to get to the k part.
I put that part
of the ket, and I
was about to do the rest of it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
PROFESSOR: It's OK.
OK.
So you can see that what happens
at the end of the day here
is that a lot of these
nk factorials disappear.
So those were not things
that we would have liked.
There is a factor of
N factorial from here
and a factor of N factorial
from there that remains.
So the answer will be 1
over ZN N factorial squared.
I have a sum over two
permutations, p and p prime,
of something.
I will do this more
closing next time around,
but I wanted to
give you the flavor.
This double sum at
the end of the day,
just like what we did
before, becomes one sum up
to repetition of N factorial.
So the N factorial
will disappear.
But what we will find
is that the answer here
is going to be something that
is a bunch of Gaussians that
are very similar
to the integration
that I did for one particle.
I have e to the minus
k squared over 2m.
I have e to the i
k x minus x prime.
Except that all of
these k's and x's and x
primes have been permuted in
all kinds of strange ways.
Once we untangle that, we
find that the answer is going
to end up to be eta
of Q x alpha minus x
prime Q alpha squared divided
by pi 2 lambda squared.
And we have a sum
over alpha, which
is really kind of
like a sum of things
that we had for the
case of one particle.
So for the case of
one particle, we
found that the
off-diagonal density matrix
had elements that's
reflected this wave packet
nature of this.
If we have multiple
particles that are identical,
then the thing is if
I have 1, 2 and then
I go 1, 1 prime, 2, 2 prime
for the two different locations
that I have x1 prime,
x2 prime, et cetera.
And 1 and 2 are identical,
then I could have really
also put here 2 prime, 1 prime.
And I wouldn't have
known the difference.
And this kind of sum
will take care of that,
includes those
kinds of exchanges
that I mentioned
earlier and is something
that we need to
derive more carefully
and explain in more
detail next time.